[Musique]
on va tout de suite se mettre dans le
bain on va se faire un petit défi si
vous voulez bien
je vais vous demander d'aller chercher
dans votre sac ou dans votre veste un
trousseau de clés
c'est pas une blague elle est vraiment
chercher un trousseau de clés
alors ça peut paraître anodin mais je
vais vous laisser une quinzaine de
secondes pour enlever une clé de ce
trousseau à une seule main
c'est pas une blague non plus faut
vraiment l'enlever à une main
et 15 secondes ça passe vite
donc l'idée de ce défi
c'est bien entendu de pas savoir si vous
allez ou si vous avez réussi
l'idée c'est de vous faire sortir de
votre cadre à vous pour vous inviter
quelques minutes dans le mien et de par
ce petit défi j'ai envie de vous dire
bienvenue dans mon monde
je m'appelle Vincent anglair je suis
handicapé de naissance on n'a pas tiré
dessus j'ai apprécié la petite vanne
mais
j'ai ça de naissance j'ai eu ça deux
séries comme une option qu'on vous donne
et depuis la naissance on m'a un petit
peu forcé la main sans faire de jeux de
mots
pour rentrer dans le dans l'équipe et
dans le cadre des handicapés alors que
moi je n'ai jamais voulu donc mon chemin
de vie a été toujours de vouloir sortir
de ce cadre où on voulait m'y mettre
qui a réussi les clés
il y en a madame ouais faudra me montrer
ce que je sais pas donc si on peut se
voir après ça serait gentil
merci merci
mais en fait c'est vrai alors comme l'a
dit Camille je suis vraiment sur
l'immobilier pour le coup et les trous
sont de clés ça me connaît et ce genre
de petit défi comme ça où tous les jours
je les évite alors pourquoi je les évite
parce que je suis de 87 ça nous rajeunit
pas tout ça et j'ai grandi en fait
jusqu'à mes 15 ans jusqu'à à peu près
Internet se démocratise j'étais persuadé
que j'étais seul au monde donc j'ai dû
trouver plein de petites solutions assez
défis en sortant un peu du cadre où on
nous dit mais il faut juste faire comme
ça tu es con c'est pas dur fais-le à
demain
donc j'ai dû un petit peu me débrouiller
et effectivement il y a des défis que je
catégorisais donc soit urgent soit
important soit Vito pour certains on va
y venir et certains
inutiles pour le coup enlever la clé du
trou saut de clé je demande à ma femme
elle y arrive très bien pour moi puis en
plus j'ai pas d'ongles
mais
[Musique]
quand on m'a demandé de faire ce talk je
me suis demandé est-ce que mes défis du
point de vue handicap allez pouvoir vous
concerner vous mais je pense qu'on est
tous plus ou moins concernés par nos
défis et que à un moment donné on doit
tous sortir du cadre parce que j'ai
appris et comme disait aussi Jean-Paul
Sartre l'enfer c'est les autres
exemple tout bête
histoire vraie il y a pas longtemps
samedi après-midi il fait beau votre
femme vient de finir un puzzle qu'elle a
mis des semaines à faire qu'elle a mis
dans un beau cadre et puis elle m'a
demandé de l'accrocher gentiment dans
les toilettes moi bon gentleman breaker
j'ai dit pas de problème j'étais sur la
cave je farfouille un peu dans mon
atelier je prends un clou je prends un
marteau je remonte
mais comment je mets le clou
il faut là pour le coup c'était un peu
bizarre je dis bon je vais faire un pré
trou quand même que je réfléchisse un
petit peu je vais chercher la perceuse
le forêt je branche tout ça
mais comment je mets le fourré sur la
perceuse
j'ai quand même réussi à lui accrocher
le cadre au mur parce que dans mon
esprit je ne veux pas que le handicap
soit supporté par mon entourage donc
j'ai continuellement eu cette envie et
ce besoin
de sortir du crade pour pas que ça soit
quelque chose qui les supporte je vois
qu'il y a des bricoleurs dans la salle
qui bricolent un peu là
elle vous demande encore avec le clou
on y reviendra
et un bon bricoleur que je suis par
moment et ben
pour reprendre cette citation que
l'enfer c'est les autres j'étais au
magasin de bricolage
et je voulais acheter une paire de gants
d'ailleurs j'espère que le vendeur est
pas là ce soir
j'ai été chez le chez le premier rayon
de bricolage du coin le vendeur m'a
demandé 3-4 fois s'il pouvait m'aider je
lui ai répondu trois quatre fois
gentiment je sais être poli que non il
pouvait pas accéder à ma requête et puis
il insista
donc du coup je lui dis bon allez il a
l'air sympa
je voudrais acheter que un gant
bah j'ai une pile de gang à gauche chez
moi ils sont tout neufs je les prête à
mes amis je l'aimais pas je pense
qu'encore aujourd'hui le serveur doit
regretter d'avoir demandé le vendeur
pardon par le serveur et d'ailleurs je
m'excuse auprès de lui mais c'est vrai
parce qu'au final sur le coup l'enfer
c'était moi pour lui et inversement
ça vous intéresse de savoir si j'ai
acheté Guingamp
oui parce que même le directeur en fait
du Casto il était pas bien
donc j'ai acheté qu'un gant au final
mais encore une fois bon c'est fatiguant
je m'amuse pas à ça à chaque fois mais
ça peut être franchement des fois des
situations un peu cocasses où on gagne
même de l'argent en fait à être
handicapé c'est super
je pourrais vous raconter bon maintenant
qu'on a bien rigolé avec le vendeur il
est pas là
je m'excuse encore furet j'ai vraiment
pas été sympa
il y a des défis qui sont des fois
vitaux et ça c'est on va dire que c'est
moins marrant maintenant qu'on s'est
bien marré avec le vendeur demain je
vous demande de couper ou de vous
alimenter et de vous nourrir et de
couper votre viande que avec la
Fourchette je peux vous assurer que vous
allez devoir essayer
donc après j'ai dû faire des essais et
encore une fois je rappelle qu'il y
avait pas Internet il y avait personne
pour m'aider c'était assez compliqué du
coup les viandes on va dire blanche ça
se coupe bien les viandes un peu plus
rouges il faut tester avec la cuisson
vous essayez de couper que la fourchette
vous en mettez partout enfin c'est le
bordel
et au final pourquoi j'ai essayé à faire
tout ça parce que mon métier et puis
même je j'aime bien manger je pense que
ça se voit
non ça va
j'aime bien aller au restaurant et puis
ton temps j'y vais très souvent avec mes
clients mes prescripteurs mes amis bref
j'ai une vie qui tourne un petit peu qui
gravite autour du restaurant
la première fois que j'ai demandé ce Mar
tu repars au clou
et la première fois que j'ai demandé un
serveur qui pouvait pas me couper ma
viande c'est les premières fois que
j'allais au restaurant il a rigolé
donc du coup je vais plus jamais
demander c'est là que j'ai commencé
vraiment à réfléchir à tout ça
et encore une fois la pizza c'est pareil
la première fois que j'ai demandé à ce
qu'on puisse me mettre un petit coup de
roulette il a rigolé il est parti mais
moi j'étais là avec ma pizza comme voilà
et en fait tout ça c'était pour malgré
le handicap rentrer un petit peu dans le
cadre de la normalité mais j'étais à
chaque fois obligé de sortir du mien et
arrêter d'écouter les fameuses bah fais
comme si fait comme ça il y a jamais
trop de personnes qui a pu m'aider
alors je vous laisse imaginer le bordel
quand je commande un plateau de fruits
de mer
ah c'est une galère histoire vraie ça
aussi il y a pas longtemps heureusement
j'ai une femme qui est géniale et grâce
à elle je sais quel goût ont les pinces
de crabe sinon je réduis les attaquer à
l'ancienne et je pense que dans le resto
j'aurais fait un petit peu de place
j'aurais plein d'histoires un petit peu
cocasse comme ça vous raconter je
pourrais vous raconter comment j'ai
appris à faire les lacets
je vois que monsieur a regardé ils sont
faits pas des scratchs j'ai arrêté je
pourrais vous expliquer pourquoi j'ai
fait mes nœuds de cravates aussi à une
main pourquoi j'ai appris tout
simplement parce que la première fois
que j'étais en stage mon premier jour de
stage en BTS
mon tuteur m'a demandé de rentrer chez
moi parce que j'ai pas mis de cravate
qu'on va
donc j'ai appris à faire les nœuds de
cravate j'ai appris à jouer à la console
j'ai appris à faire du modélisme du
quartier j'ai essayé plein plein de
choses et je n'ai jamais été dans une
catégorie handisport donc j'allais
battre les valides
c'est sympa pour moi pour eux moi
il me disait bonjour au début du
week-end et le dimanche bizarrement il
ne saluait pas je pense qu'il m'aimait
plus trop mais je peux les comprendre
c'est une bonne guerre ils sont pas bon
ils sont pas bons
et la piscine
je vous vois venir
je ne tourne pas en rond dans le bassin
merci
je ne tourne pas en rond j'ai tendance à
tourner dans ce truc là c'est un peu
mais je ne tourne pas en rond dans la
piscine et je ne suis pas comme Nemo
tout le monde voit Nemo pas comme lui je
nage très bien très vite et d'ailleurs
j'ai appris à nager je devais avoir une
trentaine d'années avec un grand nom de
la natation handisport Anita Fati qui
m'a ré appris qui m'a un petit peu
rééduquer dans la natation un bras parce
que si je vous raconte comment j'ai
appris à nager à la base c'était un peu
archaïque
je devais aller tout simplement à la
piscine avec mes petits copains à
l'époque forcément et si on reprend
cette fameuse phrase que l'enfer c'est
les autres j'étais un enfer pour mes
profs bon je l'ai été longtemps dans les
études mais là c'était vraiment juste à
cause du handicap
et du coup je devais aller assister au
cours de piscine à l'école élémentaire
primaire et je devais
allez dans le bassin où j'avais pied
donc là ça allait bien et dès qu'on
pouvait aller jouer un peu dans le grand
bain bah j'étais pas convié moi je
devais rester assis sur les gradins
et dans ma tête je dis mais c'est pas
possible pourquoi ils y vont moi j'y
vais pas bon j'ai la paluche qui marche
pas bien mais bon au final mais en fait
il voulait pas prendre le risque de
m'apprendre et je peux comprendre
honnêtement du recul je leur en veux pas
et ben j'ai eu la bonne idée de sauter
dans le bain
il y a personne qui m'a félicité sur le
moment
mais je me suis pas noyé je suis là
on m'a sûrement traité tous les noms à
l'époque là mais je devais m'en
un petit peu et c'est comme ça que j'ai
appris à noyer donc
j'ai toujours dû sortir du cadre pour
apprendre différemment on a toujours
voulu mettre dans le cadre du handicap
j'ai jamais voulu y être alors je peux
vous assurer que des fois je râler un
petit peu avec les administrations on
s'entendait pas bien
mais tous parcours de Villa m'a servi
jusqu'au jour du 29 juillet 2019 date à
laquelle je suis devenu papa
et je pensais avoir tout vu je connais
je pensais être à l'aise avec quasiment
tout je suis le premier sur la liste des
déménageurs
quand les potes déménagent ils
m'appellent pour faire du béton
bref je suis démerdard dans beaucoup
beaucoup de domaines et j'en suis sorti
mais quand on vous met un petit mogwa il
a 50 cm dans les bras et qu'on vous dit
tiens bah tu fais comme ça clac clac la
couche claque le fameux clac qui va bien
là
sage-femme je dis mais tu peux me
montrer ce que tu veux je t'écoute pas
et de toute façon ça marche pas elle
pouvait pas m'aider j'étais un petit peu
son enfer et pour le coup bah là c'était
elle j'ai mis longtemps à être à l'aise
avec le petit je l'admets maintenant
j'ai mis longtemps à l'admettre et j'ai
jamais fait tomber il est pas tombé
seul truc que je jeté par terre c'est
les manettes de la console ça c'était un
couteau un peu cher à mon père à
l'époque et du coup bah vous qui peut
être concerné par ça par un enfant bah
un peu tout le monde le premier body que
j'ai changé la première couche que j'ai
changé alors je m'étais super bien il y
avait la table à langer qui était là et
Gremlins qui était au milieu là il
bougeait pas il y avait une couche
propre là liniment et puis là en fait
dans la bagarre du caca
la couche propre elle m'a servi pour moi
pour m'essuyer
ça c'est pas trop trop bien passé
jusqu'au moment où maintenant ça va très
très bien il est même très très il
commence à comprendre il a presque 4 ans
je repense au caca sur le bœuf c'est le
bordel
et jusqu'au moment où j'ai dû lui
apprendre à nager à lui et je l'ai
emmené du coup bah à la piscine avec
maman on a été à 3 hop hop tous mains
dans la main il a toujours pas de jeu de
mots je parle vraiment comme ça et on a
appris un petit peu à nager et puis là
il y a les maîtres nageurs qui ont voulu
m'aider comme le vendeur du Casto
j'ai pas spécialement apprécié et avec
les années je suis peut-être un peu
moins corporate dans les réponses
mais je l'ai pas noyé non plus hein il
est toujours en vie
il est même très très intelligent parce
qu'il a remarqué que j'avais la main qui
marchait pas il a arraché une main sa
peluche et puis il a dit bah comme ça il
est comme papa
donc est-ce que mes petits défis du
quotidien peuvent vous servir je pense
très honnêtement cuit parce que
j'ai jamais considéré le handicap comme
une fatalité je pense qu'il ne l'est pas
je pense que c'est quelque chose en plus
qu'on vous donne à la naissance ou après
un accident il faut faire avec rien
faire c'est un peu la solution de
facilité je le vois comme ça mais qu'on
soit handicapé ou non souvent c'est le
regard des autres qui change c'est
l'enfer c'est les autres et on est un
petit peu obligé de se tourner vers les
autres et si on veut se tourner vers les
autres on est obligé de sortir du cadre
merci
merci merci
j'aurais bien applaudis avec vous mais
même ça c'est un peu le bordel
à tout à l'heure
au revoir